[Music]
[Applause]
uh sean salisbury set to join us to
clean up the mess here former nfl
quarterback and host of the sean
salisbury show on sports talk 790 in
houston i want to let people know that
sean is in his car if you're watching on
peacock you're not driving just want to
make sure that they know you're not
driving while you're doing this
interview
no i'm not pulled over for you dan
because you're special i'm not good
enough to do two things at once so i'm
gonna talk to you it's good to be on
with you guys all right uh a couple of
things to talk to you about we spent a
lot of time talking about desean watson
over the last year with you
um how do you think the uh
how did houston uh fare here in this uh
this situation
oh dan i i think i would have got more
but you what get a one and a three and a
one and a four and a one and a four in
whatever order so you get six assets i
desean watson's a better player than
russ wilson is in my mind i think he's
top five player in the league at his
position now i would have gone after
what denver did but you got to have a
player that wants to go after what
denver did and with his no trade
situation you know three first rounders
was the place to start and however you
got assets i would have loved
for the texans to grab a a player or two
that could have helped a young team and
impact them with a little veteran
experience but i don't think they got
fleeced when it comes to this but where
you do get fleeced is and for reasons we
all know watson didn't want to be here
the legal stuff is that you're getting
rid of what everybody needs in this
league ask the rams with matt stafford
denver thinks they got it with russ
wilson josh allen holmes you're getting
a top five player and you're not winning
super bowls anymore without not a guy
but that guy at quarterback
cleveland's better now they got better
baker mayfield hopefully he'll be a good
player again but deshawn watson's better
so anytime you get that franchise guy
you win the deal and deshawn's won
everything dan 230 guaranteed he gets to
go play where he wanted to play he had
to set out last year but he got paid he
gets another year where his legs are
fresh everything he did
worked to desean watson's favor football
wise so listen you had to build it
somewhere you got six assets good play
start now they got to win the draft
meeting the texans but cleveland wins
because you get a franchise quarterback
that's going to be on the field for you
at some point you get him for the next
decade and he'll be an mvp guy or
candidate every every damn year do we
just assume that he's going to write a
check and the civil lawsuits all go away
dan i
listen judging from how he's
won every step of the way i don't the
legal part
you know you hear stuff go but once the
the uh
criminal charges were dropped and pushed
you know or were done
i think teams thought the same thing now
people are going to judge where their
moral compass is about deshaun watson in
this 22 he said she said
i wouldn't know because i wasn't there
neither do you but i i would imagine the
commissioner's gonna have to do
something right i don't know what it is
but do something with the optics of this
to send a message
but
i would imagine yeah dan at some point i
don't know what the money's going to be
but if it's civil it's going to come
down to probably some some money move on
and repair your reputation play good
football and hope that the the off the
field stuff remorse or whatever it is
but desean's maintained his innocence
the whole time so dan really does come
down that cleveland has moved on and
said well we can deal with whatever
comes down to civil lawsuits we got a
great football player since he's not
going to jail
they're going to deal with this and he's
got a powerful lawyer and rusty harden
so yeah then it'll be business as usual
when the fall comes up a great
quarterback who
going to get paid 230 guaranteed million
dollars whenever he's on the field i
also wonder is there a parallel with how
the league looked at ben roethlisberger
when he wasn't charged criminally
but he got six games and then it was
reduced to four
i know this is 22 civil lawsuits here
which is different but i wonder if
they'll still look at this and maybe he
gets six games or eight games something
like that and then maybe it's reduced
can you can you see it i don't know if
there's another parallel here and maybe
i shouldn't be looking for one i'm just
looking at the punishment uh part of
this for football
yeah dan i'm right with you we were
discussing that this morning too on my
show about all right isn't that the
isn't that the the parallel you have to
compare to in our society even though at
any point in time i don't care if it's
30 years ago or now you have to take
these allegations serious well how
serious
and people's moral compass but yeah if
you're the commissioner dan i don't
think we can go the other way because
we've seen the punishment smoke and weed
one thing domestic violence and other
these situations i don't think if you're
the commissioner you can err on the side
of hey let's give him a game or two and
move on if you're gonna air
you better err on the side of protecting
women and making sure and everybody
needs to be protected but making sure
you do it the right way and if ben was
the parallel
22 of them is a bit more severe it would
it would seem
i can't fathom that he's going to go
unscathed with any kind of suspension
but i would think about as a
commissioner getting it right with the
optics and with though not just the
optics but with the moral fiber of this
our country right now is the way it
should be i can't imagine desean watson
starts the season under center in
cleveland but then again i'm not that
smart but apparently the commissioner is
going to have to make a decision soon so
the browns know what to do if i'm
deshawn's people i would expect that
we're going to miss some games and i
think that would probably be wise by the
commissioner
i was told when this uh there was the
flirting between the browns and deshaun
watson my source said the texans don't
want baker mayfield and then eventually
turned out that that was true that they
weren't interested in baker mayfield why
weren't the texans interested in baker
mayfield
dan they believe davis mills is a player
now you think about last year they
didn't have a first or second round pick
and nick casario went in and got davis
mills in the third round and people in
houston moaned about it
still wanted deshawn kind of weren't
sure he said he didn't want to be here
the legal stuff but people held out hope
that well maybe deshawn will want to
play here but it's like why would you
take a quarterback well
he starts off slow and ends the season
aside from mack jones you could argue
that the way he played he was either one
or two as a rookie quarterback so the
third round situation doesn't matter but
damn think about not just baker mayfield
they didn't try to get matt ryan they
didn't try to go in and get a russ
wilson or a star veteran they didn't
they haven't inquired about jimmy
garoppolo they didn't inquire but i mean
you go carson wins all these guys that
they're going and they they don't have
any interest in any of these first round
quarterbacks because i don't believe
there's a franchise at least immediate
changer in the draft they think davis
mills is a player now this year is going
to be important but they also saw growth
enough mentally emotionally and
physically to say we got a guy that we
don't have to spend a first rounder and
i'm not sure dan here
that they think that they think baker
mayfield's better than davis mills i
think they think they got themselves a
fairly good steal in the third round who
can spin it a little bit and who's got a
pretty bright future yeah and uh you
know he's not going to cost you we're
talking to sean salisbury former nfl
quarterback host of the sean salisbury
show on sports talk 790 in houston i
thought about you when i saw the news
about john clayton our former co-worker
um because you guys spent a lot of time
together certainly uh off camera and
then certainly on camera your
relationship was uh
back and forth
how did you guys get paired up to begin
with
yeah dan i'm taking this one's i'm
struggling with this one and i don't
mean to be emotional it's hard on me
when i got this news
friday uh over the weekend on friday
night i was i took like a 7 p.m nap i
was exhausted all of a sudden i wake up
there's like 60 messages on my phone
text message i'm like it's like in 8 30
9 o'clock at night i'm like what is
what's 60
and i look at it in all of them from
friends and our guys seth markman and a
bunch let me know that what had happened
and i was devastated because i talked to
john a handful of weeks ago seemed fine
you know he spent so much time taking
care of his great wife pat and spending
all these years being one of the best in
the business how it started with four
downs uh dan was we were in i was in the
newsroom with our guy mark chrysler and
mark shapiro wanted to do something
different mark was there at the time and
they came up to me in the newsroom at
espn and john was doing a remote
somewhere and said we want to do
something different like the nerd or the
you know the smart guy versus the jock i
said wait a minute am i the smart guy of
the
and job i said some would argue i wasn't
a jock and a
lot of them are going to say i'm not the
smart guy so they they said let's try
this and it was dan and i think john and
i were most proud of
it was the original like sports debate
thing and i didn't know it was going to
catch on like this and i still this day
you and i've talked about it over the
years
more questions about john clayton and i
and whatever you want to however you
want to ask them than any question i've
ever received in my playing time they
don't want to know if i threw a
touchdown they don't want to know who i
think the first pick of the draft how's
your relationship with john clayton and
dan you know this for the years you were
there we never scripted it yeah we were
never told what to say we would discuss
it off camera with our the people that
asked the questions and it was organic
and we let it rip and our relationship
was always special i've known him since
1986 before that but it became even more
tight-knit and close over the years
um with this and we weren't sensitive we
got it after what you saw was real
intensity but when the second the camera
went off john and i were back to being
great friends i'm i'm having a hard time
with this because i love him and he was
an original pioneer of this and dan over
all the years of covering sports and
watching it and loving it like you do i
don't know if i've ever been around a
guy
who loved talking football
on tv and radio more than john did
and like the commercial with you used to
kid him about the ponytail that's where
it started and to get that commercial
was like validation
for john he loved it dan and he's the
one guy he crawled 15 mi i mean 1500
miles to talk on a radio show at
midnight because he loved it yeah i was
honored to be his partner he was a great
a great radio and television partner and
four downs was awesome and i'm having a
hard time because he was a special
friend
uh good to talk to you and uh yeah i did
think about you because uh you know the
professor i called him johnny good times
because he yeah he always talked about
the positive he loved it's like tim
kirkchen tim always talks about the
positives of baseball and john always
talked about the positives and uh he was
always available
always you need him do a live shot
john's there need him to be a guest on
your radio show john's there always and
dan it didn't mean if it was midnight or
six a.m john didn't care a loyal friend
a loyal worker and i hope all the
insiders that come on after you know
through these years realized that this
was one of the greatest we ever had in
the business i'm going to miss him thank
you thank you bud that's sean salisbury
uh host of the sean salisbury show on
sports talk 790 in houston